six children injured in the devastating
volcanic eruption in Guatemala are in
Texas this morning for treatment for
burns a US Air Force plane carrying the
patients landed overnight in Galveston
they will be treated at Shriners
Hospital for Children the eruption
Sunday killed nearly 100 people about
200 others are missing Manuel Bojorquez
is in a squeal of Guatemala
Manuel good morning good morning
authorities are warning of the potential
for even more volcanic flows which is
why police are maintaining roadblocks
like this one to keep people away and as
residents here keep a wary eye to the
danger looming overhead we found many
are still refusing to leave after
Rotunda Fuegos biggest eruption in four
decades health is arriving to areas cut
off by the toxic flows but in the
village of san miguel most locusts now
covered in up to ten feet of ash the
chance of finding anyone alive is slowly
disappearing he says we're going to a
part of this village where rescue
workers are right now trying to recover
bodies they don't really have a sense
that there are any survivors left our
cameras were there when lifeless bodies
were pulled from the wreckage satellite
images show a striking difference of the
same town four months ago now much of it
is destroyed and what remains is covered
in mud ash and rubble you can see this
is really painstaking work they're
trying to peel back right now some of
the layers of tin roof from this one
home that was almost submerged by the
toxic flow outside the disaster area
residents lined up for hours for
supplies some say it's the first time in
days these trucks with food and water
have arrived the people were waiting in
this line tell me that the water here
became contaminated by the lava flow so
for many of them it's the first time
that they've been able to get water and
food brought to them
water is not safe good in this town
volcanic flows are within striking
distance but despite a mandatory
evacuation many are staying are you
risking yes he says to protect my home
from those who might steal with the
threat of more eruptions the evacuations
have quadrupled in size here to now
include more than 12,000 people in
addition to flying those six patients to
the US the Air Force is also donating
tools and protective equipment to help
with relief efforts Nora
alright Manuel Bojorquez in Guatemala
thank you